johnny depp and amber heard's 50 million
defamation trial rested on friday but no
rest for johnny depp welcome everyone to
entertainment tonight oh no no no just
two days after the case went to the jury
johnny was spotted jamming in london
when i was a kid all i dreamed about was
becoming a famous rock star
johnny seemed at ease hitting the stage
two nights in a row with friend and
guitarist jeff beck in the uk
[Music]
the actor who received a standing
ovation told us at the 2016 grammys he
loved performing i'm representing the
very lucky i'm the guy who
who somehow
ended up
playing in a band and having the
opportunity to write songs but is
returning to celebrity life so quickly a
good idea we asked legal analyst julie
rendellman i think there's two
perspectives an attorney can have one is
to lay low not be seen and let the jury
come to a decision without any
distractions i think the other argument
is to allow johnny depp to be johnny
depp johnny being johnny apparently also
includes staying here at this ritz
carlton in virginia during the trial
where the actor and his entourage would
quote drop one thousand dollars a night
on fine wines and have opted for the 35
chicken parmesan entree as their default
dish
today was the jury's first full day of
deliberations this afternoon jurors
asked for clarification on one of the
questions on the special verdict form
the seven jurors must answer 24
questions on the actor's claims that
amber defamed him amber's form has 18
questions it's incredibly complicated by
the way
it would be complicated for an attorney
in reviewing the verdict sheet let alone
lay people who are not normally in a
courtroom setting amber's x meanwhile is
weighing in elon musk responded to a
tweet about the trial saying i hope they
both move on at their best they are each
incredible bring me that horizon
we're also learning more about the
staggering cost of the trial why did you
file for divorce
if i did not likely not literally
survive
it's hard to understand why someone
that's supposed to love you could be
that cruel
defamation cases in general are
expensive it takes a lot of work from
both sides it takes investigation
according to one estimate johnny spent
5.5 million dollars in amber upwards of
3 million
you heard from some of the experts who
talked about exorbitant fees just for
being there for an hour two hours per
day and your billing rate for providing
trial testimony is five thousand dollars
per day that's correct so it's not
unusual for the amount to be incredibly
high
so it's a big weekend for johnny it was
also a big weekend for his daughter lily
rose she celebrated her 23rd birthday
she is currently working on the
weekend's new drama the idol